We're on problem 161.
The positive integer n
is divisible by 25.
If the square root of n is
greater than 25, which of the
following could be the value
of n divided by 25?
So what could be a valid value
for n divided by 25?
So let's see if we can
manipulate this a little bit.
If we square both sides, we get
n, right-- the square of
the square root of n is n--
is greater than 625.
And then if we divide both sides
by 25, we get n/25 is
greater than 25.
So a valid value for n/25 has
to be greater than 25.
If we look at all the choices,
there's only one value that's
greater than 25, and
that's E, 26.
Problem 162.
It looks they want to make
sure we know how
to deal with fractions.
1 over 1 plus 1 over
2 plus 1/3.
Let's just drive through
this math.
That equals 1 over 1 plus 1
over-- let's see, 2 is the
same thing as 6/3 right--
6/3 plus 1/3 is 7/3.
So this is equal to 1 over 1
plus-- 1 over 7/3 is the same
thing as 3/7-- so that's equal
to 1 over 7/7 plus
3/7, so it's 10/7.
Which is equal to 7/10,
which is choice B.
Let's switch colors.
163.
A fruit salad mixture consists
of apples, peaches, and grapes
in the ratio-- so the so the
apples to peaches to grapes--
is equal to 6 to 5 to 2,
respectively by weight.
If 39 pounds of the mixture is
prepared, the mixture includes
how many more pounds of
apples than grapes?
So they want to figure out the
apples minus the grapes.
OK, so they tell us that the
apples plus the peaches plus
the grapes is equal
to 39 pounds.
When you're dealing with a
ratio, it's useful to say well
each of these is going to be
equal to, I guess you'd call
it their ratio number times
some number, right?
Let me explain what
I'm saying.
Let's just say that apples
are equal to 6 times
some number x, right?
Well if apples are equal to 6
times some number x, then
peaches are going to
be equal to 5 times
that number x, right?
Because the ratio of the apples
to the peaches is a 6
to 5, right?
So if you did 6x over 5x,
you'd get 6 to 5.
And by the same logic, then the
grapes would be 2 times
that same number x.
And all the ratios
would work out.
So we can substitute all of
these back into that equation.
And you get 6x plus 5x plus
2x is equal to 39.
6 plus 5 is 11, plus 2--
Well
actually I have a phone call
that I was expecting.
So let me continue this
in the next video.